listen brother I wanna do some shout
outs real quick and we'll get you the
[ __ ] are you hungry
oh yeah salads only just salads that's
it I got y'all wait watch this tonight
chicken breast and salad that's it if I
give you Cuban food I would do what he
says Joe tell him about what's your
favorite meal that you want Shawn
picture show them the video I took and
they automatically go give some
shoutouts while he's finding it Jordan
Wales I don't know what the [ __ ] this
name is he Eric Thompson my man barber
Lingus Chris Bardwell Christopher
Walford Joe will let BJJ and below
average Joe I love you [ __ ]
always show him what you want
look I get it somebody though I didn't
bother he told me about this and I tried
to move to Cuba I said get him whoa up
Miami by oh my god wait T talk he dreams
about this year he wants joy this is
what he wants what that's what he wants
Joe Allen it's again well up on Miami so
he could eat that every day play the
video I love this I love this how do you
not look at it Oh
oh man go get I guess so man come
homologation you go to Miami not never
been oh well you need to go I won't come
back gosh I goo or my dad's a bit boring
believe me look at this [ __ ]
oh and I told him about pudding right
there but illegible new Salah no one is
going is going let's go we got to figure
out what the [ __ ] is wrong
what time is up what you need to open
totally I'll look it up oh my god it's
one agent right now see what time she's
open to it's 837 what time is no push
need to open shows he like we had a Rudy
Sarzo on and he would tell you told us
about putting like what is it butter in
the can in the coffee can then like
he'll of women want deke I like afraid
yeah a little bottled I mean idea
really sighs oh that when he came from
Hubert what's your favorite dessert
lungs or not the dose Mina Mina Mina boy
Salem English a linguist all right L
means yeah made coolness Nikki I was
condensed milk logic on this I now with
ice cream yeah ice cream with ice cream
100 in a China chicken inside it just
amazes put movies ice cream on the milk
cookies what kind of cookies is it
chocolate chip cookies Jesus Christ Joe
hoc and you sprinkle around you need you
need me you needed it October on it
you're gonna turn out that on Britta
well the whole time yeah she's just
Weiss yeah Jesus Christ does it oh you
knit and you put a dish in there make
only you are you putting the Michael
Michael here
and after you need it niku astonish the
human sandwich afterwards like this skew
my songs
and I cuz that is how you eat at when
you're after you weigh in
like what when you come on man get outta
here what can I predict with Jimmy go
[Music]